I want to help people.
I want to encourage people.
I want people to feel that they are valuable.
Using makeup, being a Buddhist monk, talking about equality,...
...they are both coming from the same spirit.
I consider myself gender-gifted...
...because I think I'm both male and female.
Although my body is male, I feel that soul doesn't have a gender.
When I was in the kindergarten, I really loved role-playing as Cinderella or princesses.
Because I was born in a temple, people expected me to be a monk.
People asked me, like "Oh, do you practice chanting?"
Or "Do you have to shave your head?"
And I was like. "Hell, no. I don't want to do that."
I never wanted to become a monk, because I was very skeptical.
When I was in high school, I felt that being a part of the LGBTQ+ community...
...is something to be ashamed of.
During the training to become a Buddhist monk,...
...I asked my master, "Is it okay that I'm a homosexual?
Can I still be welcomed in the Buddhist community?"
And my master said, "In Buddhism, everybody can be equally liberated.
Race, sexuality, disability, it doesn't matter at all."
This is something that I would really love to introduce to the world,...
...because I see some people are not as welcomed or respected because of who they are.
I would love to spread the equality part of the Buddhism.
So, my mission now is to inspire leaders of the world...
...to lift the laws and regulations against LGBTQ+ people and also women...
...so that everybody can be equally respected.
I am both religious and a trendy person so I can be a bridge.
I really want people to feel fluid and flexible because I think we are all unique.
I want to stretch the horizon and inspire people...
...that I can be a monk wearing heels, so you can be who you are.